[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and Speaker of amazing facts
the beautiful village of ryokan Norway
is situated in a deep valley where
mountains block the sun's rays for up to
six months every year this of course
keeps 3,400 residents in a state of
shade and sometimes depressing darkness
throughout the winter then the town
leaders got a bright idea to help
illuminate their village during the
murky months in October 2013 ryokan
installed an array of three gigantic 550
square foot mirrors on a nearby mountain
about a thousand feet above the town the
computer control and solar powered
mirrors tracked the Sun through the
winter months and reflect a giant beam
of sunshine down into the town square
brightening their lives if you visit
ryokan norway today in the winter you
can often see people gather to sitting
and benches in the town square bathing
in the reflected sunshine like those
mirrors on the mountain the Bible says
that Christians are to reflect the light
of Jesus in a dark world stay with his
friends we're going to learn more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred says that's one eight
hundred four sixty three seventy to
ninety seven let's get to our first
Bible question with pastor Doug
Batchelor and our co-host pastors Jean
Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and in just a moment we'll
be going to the phones if you have a
Bible question here is the number we've
got lines wide open if you've got a
question you want to get it in tonight's
program
800 god says eight hundred four six
three seven two ninety seven I'll say it
again you ready eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven brings your
Bible question into our studio this is a
live program and we do our best to
especially focus on living the Christian
life what the Bible teaches if you have
questions we don't have all the answers
but we've got some great Bible resources
at our fingertips and we will search the
word together eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven I am Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and pastor Doug let's
begin the program with the word of
Prayer dear father we thank you that we
can take this time to open up the Bible
and study together and we want to ask
your blessing we recognize the Bible has
been your book we need the Holy Spirit
to guide us in our understanding so be
with those who are listening and be with
us here in the studio in Jesus name Amen
amen faster that you open the program I
talking about this remarkable village
that gets there well at least a certain
dose of their sunlight during the winter
reflected off large mirrors on the side
of the mountain then I guess it shines
down into the valley and people gather
there to bathe in the Sun - just imagine
living in that darkness actually getting
out into the light how refreshing that
must be it is and I don't know if you've
been I've been up to sweet not Norway
but I couldn't believe how long the days
were in the summer sun's going down and
you know like 11:30 I can't imagine what
it's like in the wintertime and the Sun
barely comes up and then you have no
sunshine so it's already dark but then
to have no sunshine all day long and
they actually got the eye from a village
in Italy that did the same thing years
earlier that's down in the Italian Alps
but of course it's much more appreciated
up in Norway where the Sun is very
scarce in the winter and you can just
see pictures if you go online to the
people kind of gathered in this there's
this 700 square foot spot in the middle
of town that's like bathed in sunlight
and it's kind of eerie because usually
the Sun tracks across the sky but
because the mirrors are tracking the Sun
it's shining the light to the same spot
for hours each day so this you see a Sun
on top of the mountain it's really
mirrors but it looks like the Sun and it
doesn't move and but it does brighten
their lives and of course this is what
Jesus said in Matthew chapter 5:14 you
are the light of the world a city that
is on a hill cannot be hidden neither do
they light a lamp and put it under a
basket but on a lampstand and it gives
light to all that are in the house let
your light so shine before men that they
might see your good works and glorify
your father in heaven you know Jesus
said I am the light of the world but
he's willing to reflect his light
through us and Christ is the word that
became flesh and the Bible also says thy
word is a lamp to my feet and a light to
my path and so one of the ways that we
can have this light in our lives is from
the light of truth in the Bible and
maybe you'd like a little sunshine in
your heart friends and maybe you'd like
to let the light shine out of you to
others we have a free resource that will
tell you about this lamp for your feet
and light for your path called the Bible
we have a book called the ultimate
resource and it's really all about the
Bible I'll tell you a little bit about
the background of the Bible and the
different languages in which the Bible
was originally written in even a little
bit about different translations so
we'll be happy to send this to anybody
who calls and ask the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven that is our resource phone
number if you'd call that number and ask
for the book the ultimate resource book
written by pastor Doug Batchelor I think
you'll find it very informative and a
lot of Scripture again the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
book the ultimate resource and if you
have a Bible question the phone line
here to the studio eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven again
eight hundred four 63 72
97 well pastor Beck we ready to go to
our first caller for the scene good we
have Gabrielle listening from Sacramento
California Gabrielle welcome to the
program
hello my question for tonight is about
our view are you allowed to remarry well
that depends now you know of course if a
person's married and their spouse died
that have the Bible's very clear that
you're free to remarry and Paul talks
about that I think it's first
Corinthians 7 if you're married and you
divorce for biblical grounds that would
mean and you can read about this in
Matthew 5 31 jesus said furthermore it's
been said whoever divorces his wife let
him give her a certificate of divorce
but I say to you that whoever divorces
his wife for any reason except sexual
immorality causes her to commit adultery
and whoever marries a woman who's
divorced commits adultery and so Jesus
said you know what God has joined
together let not man put asunder so if a
person just says look my wife and I are
incompatible and both have been honoring
the marriage vows you don't really have
grounds biblically to divorce and
remarry
if a woman is in a relationship where a
man is being abusive you're free to
separate and of course you need to do
that for protection and especially if
there's children involved
but you know the Bible's pretty clear
that
God doesn't want us to make those vowels
in his presence and then just divorce
and remarry if someone has violated the
marriage vow then there's a reason
now Gabriel we do have a book we can
send you a free copy that is
specifically deals with this it's called
marriage divorce and remarriage and it's
a fairly new book we took the high
points of what the Bible teaches on this
and it's pretty well-covered easy to
read has some interesting stories - the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven that is the resource line and
Gabrielle will be st. happy to send you
this book where anybody wanting to learn
more about this it's called marriage
divorce and remarriage again the number
is 883 five six seven four seven ask for
the free book marriage divorce
remarriage if you have a Bible question
the phone line is eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven it's eight
hundred four sixty three seventy to
ninety seven Uriel is our next caller
from Huntsville Alabama
Uriel welcome to the program yes good
afternoon oh good evening everyone
evening how are you doing yes I'm doing
well
[Music]
the other person as well my question is
regarding the name of Jesus Christ I
would like to know where the the name
Jesus came out because I from my
understanding his name is Yeshua or
Joshua would you be able to explain that
to me if you don't mind yeah the the
name Jesus it comes from the Greek
pronunciation you know of course a New
Testament was written in Greek you are
correct if you were gonna say Jesus name
in Hebrew it would be a schewe and I
come from a Jewish background
if you say Jesus name in Spanish it's
gonna be hey Seuss
most english-speaking people
you know we use the pronounciation Jesus
and we've gotten that from the Greek now
the Lord doesn't expect us to pronounce
names in original tongues you've
probably noticed before if you've
traveled any that sometimes it's very
difficult to say things in another
language and so there's nothing in the
Bible that says God requires us to say
his name with the Hebrew accent
the reason that the angel told Mary you
will call his name Jesus and I'm sure
the angel said Yeshua is because Mary
spoke Hebrew and the name Jesus means
Savior or God saves now Jesus name is
very similar similar to the name of
Elijah Elijah is Elohim saves Jesus is
Yahweh saves and so it's Yahshua
so the names had a meaning but you know
we speak in English so god I think he
expects us to say these names in our
native tongue
exactly and and I am French so I I said
jeez you know when in my English my
French
you get away from your phone you got to
get a little closer okay yeah the reason
that we say his name in Greek is I agree
there's nothing wrong with saying the
name Yeshua
if you're preaching or if I'm talking to
people most people I'm an evangelist if
I stand up and say you know Mary had a
little baby's name was Yeshua and Yeshua
said this and they're going who's
Yahshua because most people know the
name Jesus and they know who that was so
it just confuses people sometimes if you
use the original pronunciation or the
Hebrew pronounciation so you need to
educate people what you're saying you
know we do have a book called a name of
God and I think it gets into this a
little bit and I think you'll find this
very interesting URL or anybody wanting
to learn more about this subject to get
that free book just give us a call on
the resource phone number it's 883 five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
book called the name of God again the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and the phone line here to the studio is
804 63 72 97 annex holy Celeste
listening from Madison is that Alabama
yep so let's welcome to the program by
the Alaska hi
how are you doing
[Music]
how do you prepare well first of all
don't worry about preparing small
children for the time of trouble you
know you can you can
really scare kids if you start saying
now you know this is great time of
trouble that you can't even imagine
that's coming and we're gonna have to
run into the hills and and you know and
hi and everyone's gonna be trying to
kill us and so you want to be very
careful about spooking kids like that
and of course I know some parents who
when they were kids their parents always
talked about the Great Tribulation they
grew up terrified well now they're
adults and they didn't have to in
exposed to that as kids I think the best
thing to do is if you teach your kids to
have a trusting relationship with Jesus
teach them to pray automatically to God
with their problems
they will be ready because they have a
relationship with the Lord but you know
memorizing Scripture and the promises of
God that is great preparation but I want
to you know I want to stress them out by
saying oh this is terrible time of
trouble that's coming though the Bible
says it is we don't know exactly when
that's why
all right does that make sense
all right hey we appreciate your call
Celeste very much and for anything
pastor oz we do we have a book that
talks about well that there are offer
tonight about the ultimate resource that
be good just talking about the Bible and
storing God's Word the number to call is
883 five six seven four seven you can
ask for the book called the ultimate
resource or babbitt is saying that you
celeste if you haven't yet read it or
for anyone listening the number again is
883 five six seven four seven and the
phone line once again to the studio here
with your Bible question he's 800 four
six three seven two nine seven an
ex-colleague is Jerry listening from
Medford Oregon Jerry welcome to the
program
in my Bible reading I never find any
discussion about fighting on the
Israelites fighting warring on the
Sabbath was this a problem do they take
a purely defensive defensive posture or
do you have any insight into this you
know that's a good question I just know
that I'm sure there were wars that took
place over the Sabbath
and I you know they were told in the
Hebrew law they weren't to plant their
seeds or to harvest their crops on the
Sabbath but nowhere in the law does it
say you cannot engage in war when it
came to now I don't think they probably
you know planned attacks on the Sabbath
but I do think that there were times
when they were engaged in an ongoing war
and they needed to fight well you know
you can almost guarantee it that the
enemies of Israel would I mean they do
in the different yeah the different holy
days and Sabbath's and feast days and
they probably arranged when the man in
particular would go down to Jerusalem
they probably would try and arrange some
sort of battle although God didn't
promise to protect their lights you fold
a man went down to Jerusalem during the
Passover and I like that's very good
point even during the six-day war
against Israel the some of the Arab
nations that attacked did it on Sabbath
yep and you know if his soldiers ran to
the tanks the Israeli soldiers ran to
their tanks to defend the country which
the course they have to do but they took
advantage of that and so yeah now I'm
sure that there were many times when
they had to take up arms on the Sabbath
and they understood that that was one of
the things that they were allowed to do
in an emergency
well son you know really I'm sorry go
ahead a related question is if you a
person is a medical practitioner like my
wife is a nurse well you know the sick
camp you know they still need attention
is this is this a real problem also well
no I I think that you know doctors and
nurses our church operates hospitals all
over the world and they're open 7 days a
week 365 days a year and people need to
be cared for when they're sick and jesus
healed on the Sabbath so that's
certainly appropriate what you do want
to guard against is if your work
schedule keeps you from church and
fellowship and worshiping God
corporately every week that's a problem
and you you would want to try to arrange
your schedule with your employer where
you could alternate with somebody and
say look you know I need to have some
consistency in in going to church and
just work your schedule out that way you
know pastor I even know some nurses that
you know they have to work on a Sabbath
because of shift or whatever it is some
of them feel convicted that the money
that they make during those hours they
set aside for some type of ministry
where they not benefitting by the money
but rather they are using that to help
others and it's a project commissioned
project and I think that's a good
principle it is it also keeps you from
deliberately booking correct work for
remuneration on Sabbath so yeah that is
a good idea does that help a little
Jeremy or Jerry yes all right hey thank
you very much for your call appreciate
it next Wally's what are you listening
from New York New York William welcome
to the program
contradict one another
Corinthians chapter 12 verses 7 through
9 Paul talks about having a thorn in the
flesh he asked the Lord to remove it he
did not remove it and
yet in James chapter 4 Billy the first 7
yeah you know scripture says resist the
devil he'll see from you and Paul
indicated that this message that is
thorn in the flesh came from the devil
so I want to know who those contradict
each other or what well ultimately
sickness comes from the devil I mean
even when job was he got sick it says
the devil afflicted him with boils jesus
healed a woman that was bent over for 18
years and he said this woman has been
bound by Satan you know God wants to
give healing the devil wants to give
sickness God wants to give life the
devil wants to give death but sometimes
the Lord allows just like he did with a
job he allows us to struggle with
various sicknesses or medical problems
to develop faith and if you do have
faith it doesn't mean that you'll always
be healed and never have problems God
does heal but if you do have faith it
means God gives you grace to deal with
whatever comes and to trust him so I I'm
really glad Paul said what he said there
in sick Corinthians 7 he says the reason
that God allowed it in the first verse
lest I should be exalted above measure
by the abundance of revelations Paul
heard the voice of Jesus Paul was taken
a division and shown heaven Paul had all
this information divine information from
his time with Christ and he said you
know that can make a person proud so to
keep me from being proud God allowed the
devil to afflict me with a sickness and
it's not like demonic possession it just
means you know sin and sickness it all
comes from the devil
thank you all right hey appreciate that
thank you William next fall is Chris
listening from Deer Park New York Chris
you aren't Bible answers live
I
went you know my favorite for a long
time just wanted to tell you that wow
thank you yes about the Protestant
Reformation it was such an explosive
time in you know regarding the gospel so
I'm wondering it does the Bible talk
about it at all
well yeah I think that pastor Ross is
the the revelation expert but I think
that the Protestant Reformation is
described in Revelation in a couple of
places
revelation 10 talks about the latter
part of it Revelation 12 is at
Revelation 12 where it says though or no
one of the deadly one of the heads of
the Beast was wounded with a sword
mmm-hmm and that sword that wounded the
head of the Beast was the Word of God
and that was happening during the time
of the Reformation and there's actually
a very significant time period that you
read about both in Dan in Revelation we
call it the 1260 years or 1260 days 538
through 1798 and you read about that in
chapter 12 that was a time period when
the church the true church suffered
persecution from the state Church and
yet that time period was to come to an
end and the truth was to be elevated
Hebrews chapter sorry Revelation chapter
11 talks about the two witnesses and it
says how the Spirit of God came into him
they were lifted up off the earth and
the two witnesses represent God's Word
and a study of the scriptures in Daniel
12 it says knowledge shall increase
meaning a clear understanding of
prophetic truth as relates to the
prosper information so there are a
number of references to that in the
Bible and in the Protestant Reformation
Chris really came in a couple of waves
there was the the big Protestant
Reformation where they protested what
was happening within the Catholic Church
that Martin Luther let out and then
there was like a great enlightenment
that happened after 1798 because luther
lived in 50 1500s yeah and then 1798 you
had the kind of the the Great Awakening
that took place under the preaching of
Wesley and Whitfield and some of the
latter reformers Charles Finney Spurgeon
and so forth and that's for it faded
away and we're sort of in Laodicea now
we need another awakening
you still there Chris
thank you just one more quick thought on
that the Church of Sardis when you read
in Revelation chapter 2 and 3 about the
different churches Jesus is the Church
of Sardis which would be that time of
the Protestant Reformation you have a
name that you're alive but you did so
the zeal and the enthusiasm of the
Protestant Reformation began to wane and
the Bible speaks of that prior to the
time period of Philadelphia that's a
good point these seven churches
identified very clearly appreciate your
call Chris good question
if you have a Bible question our phone
lines are open good time to pick up your
phone and give us a call and we'll try
and get your call on the air the number
to call is 804 six three seven two nine
seven are you ready 804 63 72 97 or you
know I don't even know pastor Doug how
this works but you can type in 800 god
says remember the old phones you can
actually type the alphabet on the
different numbers I don't know how it
works on a smart phone now but I think
there are little numbers are there
somewhere maybe it's somewhere there
again 846 372 97 with your Bible
question Nanak's holy is Irene listening
from
Clinton New Jersey Irene welcome to the
program
how are you doing well I was in New
Jersey last week
and she started reading the Bible and
she you know been reading some of the
Old Testament and she's it's upsetting
her and she's very fearful of God but I
was able to answer a lot of her
questions I mean there were numerous
questions her main one that I couldn't
answer and she wanted to know why if God
is so powerful and he created everything
that when he threw Satan out of heaven
why he didn't destroy Satan instead of
letting him have free reign right now
and and and still have some couldn't
some control you know over people and
everything else in the world she does
not she cannot comprehend why God didn't
destroy Satan right away that is a that
is a great question that many people
don't understand but the answer is in
the Bible first of all God made a
perfect angel named Lucifer
you know the name now gives people
chills but it was a great name and he
was a good angel and he because God
makes his creatures free that means he
doesn't force them to love him we really
are free you can't force love it stops
being loved
and so Lucifer began to circulate among
the other angels in the universe and he
began to be jealous that he didn't have
the position of Christ and their God and
and he wanted God's power and he began
to say you know if I was in charge we'd
have more freedom or if God would
confide in me and and the Lord said you
know no you're you're an angel you're
not God and you know I'm simplifying
what went on but you can read about this
in Ezekiel 28 Isaiah 14 and it talks
about this rebellion yeah now if God had
destroyed if God had destroyed Lucifer
when he rebelled the other angels would
obey God and think why Lucifer was right
God is pretty pretty fierce and he isn't
a God of love and he's vindictive and
everyone would have been fearful of God
instead of obeying God because they
loved him and so God had to allow
Lucifer to a play out what his
government policy would be so everyone
could the fruit of his rebellion and it
would never happen again and so when
Lucifer found on this planet that God
had recently made a couple that would
listen to him instead of God God said do
not eat the forbidden tree and Lucifer
said all don't listen to God the Bible
says in Romans 6 whoever you obey that's
whose servants you are and Adam and Eve
surrendered the Dominion of this planet
to the enemy and so at that point
Lucifer was able to set up headquarters
down here and use this planet as sort of
a beachhead beachhead of his rebellion
against God and so in what's happening
here on earth in the lives of people
that are you know wavering between
following God and following the devil
you've got the whole plan of salvation
that's being acted out so God had to
allow that to happen now we've got a DVD
that you can watch for free online
Eirene are you still there it's called
cosmic conflict and if you look just go
to youtube and type in cosmic conflict
you can order a DVD from us and you can
give one to your friend and it really
goes through the whole story of where
sin came from why God couldn't destroy
the devil right away but the devil will
be destroyed and all who trust God will
be saved and so God is loving God is
powerful God is good even though there's
a devil in the world God did not make a
devil he made a beautiful angel that
became a devil by his own choice
maybe listen
you know as a simplified answer of why
God
because God did not want other creatures
obeying through fear sent for the DVD
cosmic conflict Irene or anyone out
there you'll really be blessed by it you
can find it YouTube or just go to
amazing fact so our G gonna take a quick
break
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture
the Egyptians built pyramids to help
guide the spirits of their leaders Rome
sanctioned holidays to honor and appease
the spirits of their dead even the Bible
tells of a king that used a witch to
contact the spirit of a deceased prophet
today ancient folklore of spirits and
apparitions have gone from mere
superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality
scientific organisations investigate
stories of hauntings and sightings
trying to prove once and for all the
existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true
why do these stories persist
does it even matter
we invite you to look inside and find
out for yourself
visit death truth calm
[Music]
every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call
[Music]
888-814-3923
and 63 72 97 and that'll bring your
question into our bible studios I'm
still Doug Batchelor I'm still John Ross
and friends we'd love to hear from you
if you have a Bible question our next
caller is Tim listening from Louisville
Kentucky Tim welcome to the program
hi you're on the air
my question is comes from Samuel where
talks about God sending an evil spirit
torment or to punish Saul and I guess my
question is just how in a good guy
it contains no school and anything
people
alright yeah that is a good question and
in First Samuel it talks about how King
Saul who was originally filled with the
Holy Spirit he began to reject the
Spirit of God just through pride and his
arrogance and eventually it says an evil
spirit from the Lord came and
well when it says from the Lord it
basically means that God withdrew his
protection and allowed an evil spirit to
take possession of Saul because Saul had
rejected the Holy Spirit it's sort of
like in the Bible when the devil had to
get God's permission to tempt into
torment job and God withdrew his hedge
of angels the Bible says that God had
hatched headed in job with protection
and so
it's the same thing it's you know I
guess you could say well God is
responsible in that he withdrew his
protection when Saul rejected it but
really the evil spirit came from the
devil you know there's an interesting
parable that Jesus told you can read
about in Matthew 12:45 and in Luke
chapter 11 verse 26 about an evil spirit
that's cast out of a person in Jesus is
he sort of wanders around looking for a
place to call home and then he goes back
to the person he finds the person of the
house as is described by Jesus cleansed
and and swept and neat and he goes and
he gets seven others worse than he and
they move in and the second condition of
the person is worse than the first in
other words uh we can't be the vacuum in
our life the vacuum is filled by the
devil in the case of Saul he was filled
with the spirit but he hardened his
heart grieved away the Holy Spirit when
the Holy Spirit left the vacuum was
filled by an evil spirit and sometimes
in the Old Testament God is described as
allowing things as being the one who
sent it or made it happen yeah they saw
God is sovereign and so anything that
happened they felt he must allow it
somehow does that make sense him sure
is by that same rationale would you say
in present day that that applies
two
terrible things or things that might
happen nowadays where God allows
certainly you know could be a tornado or
an earthquake or anything like that well
kind of ask answer your question with a
question do you think anything surprises
god no answer yeah God doesn't say Wow
and didn't see that coming God knows all
things God obviously has power to alter
or interrupt I'm sure the devil has
plans often to cause disasters that were
saved from we never even think about but
sometimes because this world is a
battlefield between good and evil for
His purposes that we won't understand
all of them till we get to heaven I
don't know if we'll ever understand all
of them but we'll understand things a
lot better God does allow certain
calamities to come to try to redeem to
try to get our attention sometimes the
troubles that come are to chastise us it
says you know and the Lord may even use
the devil now I know that sounds strange
but when the children of Israel turn
from God God withdrew his protection and
enemy pagan nations came and conquered
them and then they turned back to God
and God would deliver them and so God
allowed these enemy nations to sometimes
be a a
chastisement or a lesson book or a
punishment to his people it's the same
thing with the Devils as it was with
these pagan nations God sometimes allows
it for whatever reason sure the
be-all-end-all he meant it for evil but
but I'm I'm in it for good exactly yeah
he can turn it all to to get like it
says there in Romans work it all for
good thank you all very much all right
good question appreciate that thank you
Tom no Tim next Holy's Kimmy listening
in Bismarck North Dakota Kenny welcome
to the program yeah I was gone doing
well thank you for your call how can we
help you tonight my question is if a
person
did did something wrong to another
person but yet that person I asked for
forgiveness but I never approached that
person did you still have a chance to go
to heaven well now let's just use a
scenario let's suppose that a person did
something mean and hurt someone or
whatever and they died and you can't
never asked him for forgive
but you repent and you tell god of
course they can be forgiven if that
person that has been wronged is alive
the Lord says as far as possible we
should try to or you know write a letter
be reconciled confess repent and
restore the relationship even if the
other person doesn't forgive that's
between them and God you should
apologize and and try to do what you can
to confess your fault Christ said you
know if you're going to God and asking
for power or forgiveness if you bring
your gift to the altar and you've got
you ought against your brother says
leave your gift set it down go be
reconciled to your brother then bring
your gift so us forgiving and getting
along with each other to the Lord is
about as important as anything yeah I'm
I'm kind of I'm kind of speaking for
somebody that has an ego that he said
that a man does not have to apologize
for his wrongdoings yeah well it's
that's just simply not true and I know
it's a person's yeah if a person the
whole plan of salvation is about
confessing our faults repenting and
accepting forgiveness if a person feels
like they have nothing to confess and
they can't humble themselves that's a
pretty serious condition because pride
someone said once you're never more like
the devil than when you're proud right I
know it's kind of hard this person that
you're this person you're thinking of
they're still alive I assume yeah pray
form pray that god will humble their
hearts and they'll see that they need
forgiveness and that they're human I
know I've met people like that they said
I don't need to pray God's too busy and
I'm you know I have nothing to confess
and and they just they can't humble
themselves it's difficult you just pray
for them and they often can and they're
not and then pastor just on a short note
here um
everybody that's listening they're wrong
the United States we need to pray for
this country but to to turn it back
around the way our forefathers founded
it on Bible principles amen yeah I
believe that's true and we appreciate
that comment thank you very much Kenny a
next call is Kevin listening from
Washington Kevin welcome to the program
as to Doug my question is in the Bible I
think there's a scripture says that
there are worlds without number like
grains on the sand
my question was is there other worlds in
this universe that are populated with
beings such as us well I do believe the
Bible teaches there are other unfallen
worlds with creature whether they're
like us or not I suspect they're not
exactly like us because
you know God made man in His image and
there was something unique and special
about what he did in this world but I do
believe there's other intelligent life
throughout the limitless space that God
has made just statistically you would
think that but even in the Bible I think
it's in Hebrews chapter
might be Hebrews chapter 1 where it says
let me look at that real quick and
yeah god it's verse 2 God who at various
times and in various ways spoke in time
past by the father's to the father's by
the prophets has in these last days
spoken to us by his son whom he has
appointed heir of all things and through
whom he also made the worlds through
Jesus he made not world worlds and then
in Revelation it talks about all the
creatures in heaven and all the
creatures on earth praising God and
Colossians it talks about God made the
worlds and so yeah I think that there
are and then there's a parable Jesus
told the Kevin where Christ said that a
man had a hundred sheep and he said 999
of him made it safely back to the fold
but one was lost and he left the fold
and he left the Sheep and he went in the
wilderness to look for that one lost
sheep well Christ has got this you know
universe of unfallen creatures but he
left them all because of this world that
was lost Christ said are you sick that
need a physician so he came here to save
us but I think there's unfallen worlds
out there
well pastor Doug thank you very much for
all the ministry up at 3abn and I watch
you all the time I've been doing all
your Bible studies on a baby Christian
thank you well thank you very much Kevin
you just stay close to the Lord and find
a local church and that teaches the
Bible and worship with yes looking on
being baptized seventh-day adventists
right away Oh bless your heart thank you
annex Kohli's michele listening online
and michele welcome to the program hi
thank you thank you for all the work
that you guys are doing my question to
you guys is do babies go to heaven and
the reason I asked that is I know
children will be in heaven I've read
that passage but I came across another
passage I didn't write it down and it
made it sound like you had to be of age
to kind of acknowledge there was an
existence of God of some sort so if you
can kind of help confirm for me there's
like you know how that would happen for
you know young babies that died all
right that is a great great question and
it is a difficult question
at the heart of the question first of
all I don't think there's any doubt that
the children whatever their age of
believing parents if the children have
not yet reached the age of
accountability obviously if you're a
parent and you're a Christian then
you've got an adult child that turns
from God they have that freedom just
like the prodigal son did
and you know they hopefully will come
home and you pray for him but there's no
guarantee even God was a perfect parent
and he just lost some children because
of sin so
the question is what about all the
babies that died before the age of
accountability whether it's you know
three years old or six months old or
three days old do they all go to heaven
and
you know this is a difficult question
but if you know I once commented to a
friend that I wasn't sure that every
aborted baby was going to be in the
resurrection and they became very upset
with me but there is a verse in the book
of Joel that talks about an untimely
birth meaning a miscarried baby the job
is cursing the day he was born he says
that I might be as though I had not been
like an untimely birth that came from
the womb to the grave now I'm
paraphrasing it's in the like third or
fourth chapter and
so there may be some you know infant
children or aborted babies and if
they're not going to be yeah you think
about it you do the math heaven is gonna
be a nursery and the saved people are
gonna be swimming in babies
if every if every miscarried or every
aborted baby is in heaven now I do
believe that the the miscarried or
children that are lost the believers are
there and you read in 1st Corinthians 7
it says that the believing parent has a
sanctifying influence on the unbelieving
spouse and the children
you know I'm just thinking of this story
where in the New Testament when Herod
gave the decree to destroy all the baby
boys tears and under and
then it quotes
Jeremiah 31 16 that says the weeping
those who weep shall be comforted for
they shall coming in from the land of
the enemy talking about the children the
promise of the resurrection so I think
it's pretty clear for a believer yes
they're their babies will be born
resurrected I should say when Jesus
comes again
maybe somebody who never had a child
here on this earth and for whatever
reason and yet wanted a child maybe
there will be some babies available so
to speak in the resurrection that they
get to raise in heaven we don't know at
the Bible although there will be babies
in heaven no question about that oh yeah
so it's I think we've just it's one of
those
one of those mysteries I think we need
to be careful not to say that every baby
that is conceived believer or unbeliever
that dies before the age of
accountability automatically goes to
heaven
yep I better stop there I'm no I'm
making people mad now anyway
that I know that's heartbreaking
thank you all right well you've got the
you've got the blest assurance as a
believer
okay well thank you all right god bless
my next holy is Dale listening in
Belleville Michigan Dale welcome to the
program
Dale you there yeah
yes I'm here you're on the air okay
I wanted to know you know an earlier
Collard was talking about divorce and
remarriage and I wanted to know
what happens when there is a couple and
there is conflict and only one person
wants to admit two problems and the
other one just wants to change the other
person
because they believe that the other
person is totally at fault and they will
not make any change
the person the person being my wife she
didn't she thought all the problem with
me and we needed to go to counseling to
change me to fix me and to make me
believe that her way was the right way
and eventually I just left I left the
marriage
she was bitter and filed for divorce
neither one of us have remarried
I'm not sure that I feel justified in
remarrying and
but I feel I feel just a lot of conflict
over it and
it still is still a bitter issue even
after 10 years we can't hardly spend any
any time in family or function or
anything share some children together
I'm sorry do you share children together
yes three and how long were you married
22 married 22 years yeah that is very
difficult and you know I regret hearing
of course that that there couldn't be
counseling for both I'm not saying whose
fault anything was obviously we don't
know but it was extensive convoy yeah
and well you know it it it is difficult
marriages often have challenges of
people trying to get along and once you
make the vow and the covenant the
Bible's pretty clear that it's it's as
serious as it gets that God wants us to
keep that covenant
once you're in a position where you know
you guys we had 10 years of what
separation now
you almost can't unscramble the
scrambled eggs the question then would
be if people divorce without biblical
grounds if it is a sin is it the
unpardonable sin well no I mean it could
be under some circumstances I suppose
but there's cases in the Bible of people
that were divorced and remarried many
times and evidently saved and I'm
thinking about that Samaritan woman that
Jesus talked to at the well in John
chapter 4 so and Jesus you know he saved
her he revealed he was a messiah so
there are gonna be people who are
divorced without biblical grounds and
and they can find forgiveness but it
doesn't mean it wasn't a sin you
see what I'm saying yeah and you know
and then again you may you know from you
may not have biblical grounds for
remarriage
which is you know sobering thought
so all I can tell you is what Jesus said
and in Jesus says in Matthew chapter 5
31 and in Matthew chapter 19 9 it's in
mark chapter 10 11 Luke 16:18 Romans 7 3
first Corinthians 7 11 it talks about
what the grounds would be for divorce
and remarriage and you know you would
enjoy the book that we offered earlier
Dale on marriage divorce and remarriage
it just goes through the scriptures and
in a pretty objective way
would you like a free copy of that yeah
that would be great yeah we'll be happy
to send that to you the number to call
is 883 five six seven four seven and as
for the book marriage divorce and
remarriage and we'll send it to you
daily anybody who calls and asks and
would like more information about that
annex collie is a Robert listening in
Washington Robert welcome to the program
Robert hi how are you doing doing good
how can we help it to time to ask about
the Sabbath okay about the two laws
passing
one
was saying in Exodus 12 17 were supposed
to I guess it's the ordinances we're
supposed to keep forever kind of thing
the Bible verse says rise that's about
the Passover we're supposed to keep the
Sabbath as well so why are we not for to
keep the the ordinances which one says
forever but we're supposed to keep the
tablet yeah well the principle of the
ordinances I think does last
the in other words they had ordinances
for instance the Passover there was an
ordinance that they were to sacrifice a
lamb at sundown now do you think we
still should do that now that Jesus has
come
no okay so that ordinance obviously has
changed the way we keep it we do still
remember the deliverance of the
Israelites from the Angel of Death
because Jesus delivered us from death by
his blood the blood of the Lamb saves us
so all of the lessons from the Jewish
feasts are they are to still remember
but they were part of the annual
Sabbath's they're not like the Ten
Commandments the Sabbath day of the Ten
Commandments existed before there was
even sin and it says of course we'll
keep it in heaven in Isaiah 66 so
there's the ceremonial laws I think are
the laws of what Paul is speaking in
Romans 14 where he said if you're going
to regard a day regarded to the Lord if
you're not going to regard the day to
the Lord you don't regard it it in other
words if you want to remember the
different the Jewish feasts there's no
prohibition against that but it's not
required of believers
okay alright well thank you that helps a
lot all right here appreciate your
question you know I think we have a book
pastor Doug on the subject called feast
days and Sabbath's we didand I think
you'll find that interesting Robert or
anybody wanting to learn more about this
the number to call is eight hundred
eight thirty five six seven four seven
you can ask for the book feast days and
Sabbath's I next caller is Brian
listening from Oklahoma City Oklahoma
Brian welcome to the program hey are you
doing pastors good I have a two-part
question one was on predestination is my
you know our future already written and
I also was wondering where does it say
limp or disobedient we don't listen to
the Lord that he can cause us to believe
a lie all right two questions we just
got a couple minutes left so we'll have
to give you a quick answer
pastor Ross is gonna look up the verse
for me they receive not the love of the
truth I think it's a first or second
Thessalonians God will send them strong
delusion that they should believe a lie
you got that already yes
looking it up and your first question I
was about predestination is our future
already written well because God knows
the future does not mean we don't have a
choice and the idea of predestination is
well if you're gonna be saved you're
gonna be saved and don't you worry about
it don't you make a choice because
you're either the elect or you're not
and you know that's an extreme view but
obviously we do have a choice that's why
God says choose ye this day who you will
serve and whoever believes in Him and
whoever will let him come and take the
water of life all through the Bible it
talks about us making choices
2nd Thessalonians chapter 2 and verse 10
he's the verse you're looking for what
are we dead yes it says and with all
deceivableness of unrighteousness in
them their parish talking about the
antichrist power because they received
not a love of the truth that they might
be saved verse 11 says and for this
cause God shall send them strong
delusion that they should believe a lie
yeah so that means when you reject the
truth when you turn your turn or close
your eyes to the light the result is
darkness all
right so does that help a little Brian
very good hey we appreciate your
appreciate your question we'll be happy
to send you that free book that we
mentioned earlier tonight called the
ultimate resource and you and friends
anybody listening if you just go to the
amazing facts website a lot of the books
that we offer during this broadcast you
can get them for free and it's simply
you can read them online amazing facts
dot o-r-g if you type in amazing facts
comm dotnet it'll still take you there
and you hear it yourself we just by
faith send out a lot of free Bible
material to people who are listening
we appreciate your keeping the ministry
in your prayers and in your support
don't go away have a couple of more
important announcements
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95 minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today
visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
WWF a-kor G and sign up for our free
Bible study course and make sure to
check out our online bookstore at AF
bookstore calm which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
$887
RG did you enjoy this program make sure
to tell your family and friends tune in
next time for more Bible answers live
honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions
[Music]
on Christmas Eve 1971
seventeen-year-old juliane koepcke
boarded Lanza flight 508 with her mother
in Lima Peru they intended to join her
father for Christmas at his research
station in the Amazon rainforest
after crossing the Andes at about 21,000
feet their aircraft was enveloped by
large dark thunderclouds and it
encountered severe turbulence lightning
was flashing everywhere and the plane
was shaken violently which naturally
terrified the passengers then a bolt of
lightning struck the planes engine and
tore off a wing as the doomed airliner
hurtled towards the earth the cabin came
apart and the next thing she knew
Julianne found herself strapped alone to
a row of seats falling and spinning
silently from over 10,000 feet above the
rainforest she plummeted through the
jungle canopy and slammed on the forest
floor when she awoke the next day
Julianne was amazed to realize she had
survived the two-mile fall with just a
broken collarbone and a bad gash in her
arm after failing to find any other
survivors Julianne relied on what her
father had taught her that walking
downstream will always lead the
civilization so with a bag of candy that
had fallen from the plane and one sandal
she started walking for ten days
Julianne hobbled swam or floated
downstream her wounds became infected
and she was plagued by maggots while
having to dodge crocodiles piranhas and
relentless insects
eventually she came to a shack where she
slept and she was soon discovered by
Peruvian loggers
eventually Julianne was United with her
amazed father it's hard to imagine a
17-year old girl surviving such a fall
and then hiking alone out of the world's
largest rainforest
you know the Bible talks about some who
survived an even greater fall than
Julianne in fact according to the
scriptures when Adam and Eve fell in the
garden beaten it brought the whole human
race down but Jesus came to redeem the
world from sin perhaps you're thinking
to yourself well that's ok for the world
but I fallen too far
well if the Lord could save Julianne God
can save you you've not gone farther
than Moses who is guilty of murder or
David who is guilty of adultery or Peter
who denied Jesus and all of them were
saved and restored from their fall or
maybe you're thinking I've fallen too
many times be of good courage it says in
proverbs chapter 24 verse 16 a righteous
man falls seven times and rises again
and Jesus cast Seven Devils out of Mary
Magdalene so don't get discouraged
friend if you've fallen get back up
again the same way that he could save
Julianne lead her from that lost
condition in the rain forest and restore
her to her father Jesus can lead you
from your lost condition and restore you
to your heavenly Father
[Music]
for over 50 years amazing facts has
shared the wonderful news of salvation
and provided millions of Bible resources
to people all over the world we've built
churches in India proclaim God's Word in
China and have sent free Bible studies
around the globe today's program and
free resources were made possible by our
ministry partners caring individuals
like you if you've been blessed by
amazing facts would you please consider
partnering with us to reach others with
the Bible truth your financial support
today will help keep programs like this
on the air so the blessings you've
received can be shared with others to
find out more about becoming a ministry
partner please visit our website and at
amazing facts PO RG
[Music]